dungeon train I had no voice for that so
that's what came out so now we know he
has was a four seconds something else
for yeah okay that's good that's gross
I'm super good BAM and what's the other
one brain what's the other one that's
gross we said that I'm sorry that was it
I'm sorry okay oh so yeah so this is I
love the idea of this one they're gonna
go to the Sun sir Kate some sort of
adventure cave mystery cave and they
come across this train that's going in a
circle out turns out it's a dungeon
train and you just keep going in a
circle message it's not drugs it's just
gum trying to tell me something no my
breath stinks I don't know about yours
don't get close enough I'm trying to be
nice there's always somebody about
people who are chewing and talking that
I used to not mine but now that I get
older it just seems when doing a V log
it seems on pro you release a little bit
I can you talk about your love my ass is
much more professional hoping eyes on
say that again no the way you said
before okay but we're staying
professional alright so like on this
train it's a dungeon train it goes
around around and you just go on each
one defeating a boss and getting loot
and it seems to never end and you start
to figure out I'm assuming they're
saying that the people on there they
were being fought were also people that
came aboard and became the bosses it
seems like if they got too addicted yeah
so Jake sees this is gonna happen that
there's a little crystal that shows you
the future and he sees that Finn's gonna
be there as an old man he just stays
there and Finn doesn't seem to mind he's
like you know no no it's great cuz you
know he doesn't have to think about
Flame Princess he doesn't have to think
about you know the emptiness
as he can just keep playing this over
and over and over but then things start
to change when Jake sees there now Finn
sees that Jake is gonna stay there with
him it doesn't want that to happen to
Jake so he tells them oh it's cool I'll
get off in a few weeks it's like no
that's the Train talk it's like oh we
eat says don't get off in a week or two
and Jake says nuts the Train talk and
it's like no no it's all really doing
here look in the crystal eye shows them
washing dishes and apparently that seems
right so yeah it's pretty solid as
pretty clever the only thing that really
just Jimmy will be gathering me off is
why would he stay on for a week or two
that genuinely threw me off does that
get continued into the next one oh no no
no it's I just think it's because he's
clearing his mind getting back like you
said last episode he just wants to do
some adventuring he's kind of sick of
the love stuff he wants to get back into
adventuring last episode we didn't get
any adventuring this one that's what
he's kind of fulfilling he's getting
that need that desire for adventuring
out of them we're gonna get it like in
the mystery cave or something or I guess
I think this is more or less a non-stop
thing where the mystery cave sooner or
later will be an ending this you can go
on as long as he kind of wants to unlock
away okay and now he's sure that he can
walk away at a certain point so I don't
know if that's a good thing or a bad
thing because it's like you know I've
know a few people with like addictions
and stuff and anytime somebody says any
time somebody says no no it's cool I'm
just gonna do a few more or this is
gonna be it or something it it rarely is
so that's the one thing that threw me
off a little bit is that it's because I
think we're sir Sir he gets addicted to
the world pretty much I mean there's so
he's gonna stay there you know for the
rest of his days and he doesn't change
something so that's why I think it threw
me off a little bit not to say that
though I guess you're way look at is
like he's so confident he's beaten it so
well that he knows he can leave in that
amount of time and be okay well I also
think that once he saw like what's gonna
happen to Jake not him he's kinda like
oh yeah I'm gonna have it
some life is gonna be great wait Jake is
with me the entire time and he's
incredibly miserable I'm not gonna do
that to my friend hmm that's why it says
no you need to leave I'm gonna be on
your for a bit longer everything will be
cool you know I'm gonna do it to his
friend okay I guess I couldn't say yeah
cuz no matter what they'll always be
like because Jake will always come back
as I guess so okay I guess fair enough
um what did you take out of this episode
only here were you think first yeah
no no cuz I in other words you don't
know what to say yours gonna feed off of
what I say no ish no it's one of those
things where it's like I start look at
this I'm like boy I know there's like a
couple ways you could sort of look at
this or interpret and stuff but okay
here's the thing I'm not a gamer okay I
I used to be you know it into like
whatever all the old Nintendo games and
stuff like that but since I've gotten
out of it I know gaming is like pretty
much bigger now that's ever been I mean
it's just huge and I know that there can
be these communities in this world where
you can just stay on forever and it can
just be like this huge escape um I was
thinking maybe that's kind of the lean
you know that they're going for but at
the same time we saw saw that before
when you hand like the little pins and
the little bubble gums and stuff and you
serve doing it you know count like The
Sims or whatever so I didn't know if
that's kind of what they're going for or
not or they're lean towards cuz I don't
know if that's like a common thing or
not it's like you know do people use
like video games to escape and then they
just like to escape friend something
really painful and then they just sort
of really stay there like the action
game sort of things not something where
you can create another you and like
interact with people I mean just shoot
him ups and adventures and stuff like I
I don't know what that's a thing you
know so or could just be like an
addiction to but I'd seen they were
called in to another episode of
addiction so I'm not sure if if they
didn't do those other episodes I'd
probably say it's one of those things
that they're trying to lean towards but
because they kind of have already I
wasn't exactly sure what what like what
the main folk
was supposed to be I mean all those
elements I'm sure in there but what the
main focus they're trying to pinpoint is
well I hope you're not asking me if I
know what the main focus okay you know
you know I just took it as Ben needed to
escape beam fifteen beam pin just kind
of needed to get away from everything
that's going on and do some adventuring
and it's kind of like see I saw the
dungeon train more as like the Final
Fantasy series stuff like that where and
I'm a huge fan of the Final Fantasy
series I've played all of them except
for three original three not American
three home plate all of them all of that
stuff and I love them but they bring up
some very specific in this it's the same
car we've done the ants already and
Finn's like oh no the other ones were
blue these are red that's um that is
common in Final Fantasy you know or even
Dragon Warrior or you know the like
where oh it's the same monster you just
colored different and they're kind of
called something else so I don't know
play if it's necessarily a knock that
the Final Fantasy games or not but
that's very much what it is now you
fight one slime or flan and there's like
four different ones and they're just
different colors I guess they have
different powers in a sense but they're
spoke kind of the same excuse me so I
took it more as that that he's just kind
of going into an extensively long video
game session and and for a while you
know a couple weeks you will be pulling
out of it and he'll be fine
it's not something he's going to be in
forever I mean we're not anymore now
vanity well yeah well like Final Fantasy
there's a beginning and an end most
online gaming there's no true ending you
can gonna just keep going and going and
going so with this I think it was more
uh look here's an adventure starting
there will be an end to this sooner or
later even though technically it doesn't
egg is going as circle meheecan for the
player themselves like Final Fantasy
yeah you can run around doing side
quests or continue to level up or
whatnot but once you just finish the
full-on plotline it's over well over
yeah that's my guess and well what's all
I know I had he said you know a final
fantasy the title that has no idea what
the word final means as they keep making
sequencer there's my only problem with
that is up until 10 they were final hmm
each game is its own self-contained
world none of them were sequels of the
past ones I know nothing about Final
Fantasy one had nothing to do with two
three four five six two had nothing to
do with I mean the others never remember
anything to do with anything else up
until 10 when they made 10 - so they
were actually the Final Fantasy before
that maybe no I should do a little bit
more research before he speaks the truth
though I'm even lying well no I mean
it's I
well no no now Final Fantasy has gone
bonkers and they've made sequels for a
ton of the stuff a statement I never got
like that I mean now I kind of
understand now that you explained it
because I would see like a 12 point two
or a three and I didn't get it so okay
now he didn't individual one is it was
supposed to be exactly a like its own
some kind of amazing it's just Final
Fantasy 8 you know there will be like
bleeding over characters or kind of when
I say characters it's like Oh there'll
always be some character named Sid and
pretty much every Final Fantasy game but
it's not the same Sid okay it's kind of
a little nod it's a running gag if you
will okay um I'm not looking to start a
fight I'm having fun but but no that's
what I took this as more as that type of
role-playing game
um not Zelda anyone that says it's
reminds them of Zelda person that's all
I thought of when watching it but I know
it's not like I say a bomb cellmates I'm
telling myself
okay there's I know there's other games
to come out they're probably more
similar than this yeah another problem
is just any types aren't just
role-playing game first thing that pops
in the heard of still dough
oil eggs older soldiers will play game I
know
stop it there's like 10 billion out
there that are so much better and so
much more well written
and not as so complicated as the zelda
world is zelda should be final zelda it
should just stop just stop and it's that
i stopped after like was a great one
yeah ocarina of time I mean that's work
should have stopped yeah that's what
everybody says like that's the big you
know like maybe Twilight Princess okay
really sidetracked
okay so the only other thing I could
read then what you were saying is that
you need time to escape you know just
sort of breathe and you know just do
some adventuring you know just some just
sort of time to himself you know anyone
dumbing activities yeah yes it's still a
hobby still so had to keep him active
but if he doesn't keep it in check he
could get stuck there as well so it's
good to have it's good to have something
to return to something to come back to
and he does he has Jake exactly okay so
that that kind of makes sense like it's
good to have a hobby it's good to have
something else to get your mind off of
you know keep your mind active don't
keep it depressed don't keep it sad but
don't get stuck there either still have
something to come back to well like when
I'm playing a video game
Elson after a while I'll be like oh crap
I got to pick up Bri from school you
know three hours late it's something to
come back to I remember
mmm girl yes she's over there I wish
we've been throwing your Oh crud sister
forget my child exists every listen
alone yeah wow you're a great parent oh
so did you notice in this episode are
like yeah just the arm again
Diddy yeah I missed that where did he
have it wasn't one of the extra things
they had what is old oh no I missed that
when he's old he's got the mechanical
arm again wow I'm so wondering if that
you know if that's just sort of like a
running gag now a running thing or if
they have to like or they're actually
planning that with something
we really curious if they're ever gonna
do something with it um I mean it's very
brief and you only see it briefly but
you're gonna show me right now no well
we're still talking the other thing I
really thought was kind of neat is the
moon he gets the battle moon that
circles around that thing I love that
thing because also in the future shot
it's no longer than just a moon it's a
planet with its own moon all of that I
didn't notice even so neat I'm like
that's freaking funny you know actually
we're gonna start oh you're right okay
it's not and there's seven the exact arm
oh you're right there's the oh but yeah
he just saw but I said the one line I
really liked in this I don't know way
it's I only know if you can say the
throwaway line whatever but I like I
like what Jake is saying there he's
looking at the Stars I love that that
thing waits until morning to attack yeah
no waits until the morning is like I do
it it's like wait till the morning um I
really like we just look at the stars it
just says what my kids are doing right
now and I don't know why I really like
and they that does harken back to what
you were saying about like Finn will go
back because he has somebody there
waiting for you know he has Jake yeah
you know he has somebody there to you
know to go back to yeah he has something
important outside of this so I mean
there's more than this then I kind of
thought there was see that's why I like
talking about it because that way we
could talk us I thought it was just sort
of like a hey you can get addicted to
you know whatever other realities don't
and stuff but no now I see it it's like
this is especially after a breakup or
just losing something I was very close
it's very it's okay to have something to
occupy your mind you know a hobby or
something to keep you active just don't
get stuck there have something to go
back to that were important Finn's going
back to what he's really good at he's
good at dungeon crawls he was not really
good at love but he's really good at you
know dungeons and defeating monsters so
he's going back to what he's really good
but at the same time that's not every
that's not what matters most what
matters most is Jake is
friends people you know something to go
back to yeah that's that makes sense no
that's the statue good episode meow
your breath does stink
sorry
check yours shut yours
shut shut come on plug ears okay what my
kids are doing right now